[Music]
all right it's question of the week time
or one what do we call it one question
friday i like that all right one
question friday uh sam is traveling so i
got my boy ben here ben levy not been
the not producer ben not powerful
producer ben this is ben levy the uh the
ceo of the milk road and uh my business
partner across my fund and a bunch of
other things you guys hear me reference
ben a lot but you never know which ben
because i only deal with ben's so uh
this is one of the bends ben what's up
man
what's going on i'm riding high today
chris paul and the suns won by like 25
last night so i've never been happier
this is true um all right so
let's let's do this one question uh i
think we have an audio clip right let's
play let's play the audio clip i haven't
heard this yet so let's see what it is
hey guys my name is colin um i just had
all of my nfts stolen today
so
my question is
and i'm sure you've been through
something like it before
um
you know
when you get gut punched like
has that happened to you
uh what happened and how did you work
through it oh man i could feel the
defeat i could feel the uh
the pain in his voice there at the end
that thank you that was a soul crushed
thank you uh okay so
colin you got your nft stolen i you know
i feel for you that's no fun i mean
that's a it's a crime right somebody
came and stole your property it's
digital property but uh you know a crime
has been committed so you know you got
to kind of separate
um here's my my kind of advice to you
have i had somebody steal a bunch of my
property before uh
not really but you know there's
different flavors of of gut punch and
i've had i've had my share
so
here's my kind of like formula for how
to handle it
the first step
is
just be still
um and i mean this in kind of a zen way
which is that
look what's going to happen you know for
the next 24-48 hours for you is you're
gonna your mind is gonna go to a bunch
of different places you're gonna get
angry you're gonna feel sad you're gonna
feel upset at yourself you're gonna feel
upset at others you're gonna feel upset
at the the fact that you can't get it
back so you're gonna hate crypto you're
gonna you're gonna feel a bunch of
emotions by default and what you wanna
do is you want to not
um just react you want to respond so
what's the difference between a reaction
and a response a reaction is what you do
uh you know sort of right away it's an
impulsive thing
and typically we don't love our
reactions to things because our
reactions are the things that are
happening in a more primal way was that
whereas our response is what happens
when we pause for a second
and we
we choose how we're going to respond so
a reaction is typically not something
you're choosing a response is something
you're choosing and i this happens to me
multiple times a day where i got to
check myself all right am i reacting or
responding here and which one do i want
to do i know i can do both but i'd
rather respond and so the first thing is
you got to be still you got to distance
yourself
from it emotionally
first
then you got to say all right well how
am i going to respond to this well
there's some like logistical steps you
might take to try to get back report it
try to figure out who did it
you know notify people in the community
so other people don't fall for it
whatever the scam was
but then you gotta like okay let's say
you've done the logistics part
um and maybe there is no happy ending
where you didn't just all turn out right
that's where you got it what i call you
got to decide what story is true
so in any event
uh anything that happens there are there
are multiple stories but to simplify
i'll say
there's two stories anytime something
happens
there's the story that'll make you feel
bad and there's the story that'll make
you feel good
they're both stories right uh and they
both have truth to them but it's just a
matter of which which angle you're
looking at something and so you gotta
decide which story am i gonna roll with
am i gonna roll with the version of this
that makes me feel really bad or am i
going to roll with the version of this
that makes me feel good and i know that
probably sounds hard in the moment you
just got a bunch of your stolen and
uh you know which is why we first you
know tried to distance ourselves from it
but that's where you're going to have to
go you're going to have to decide the
version of this story that's going to
make you feel good right imagine a
breakup most people when they have a
breakup in a relationship they feel bad
and they choose a story that's going to
make them feel worse which is oh my god
all the all those years we spent
together it's time wasted i'm not good
enough or she's not good enough or
whatever the reasons are right we have
we come up with a story that makes us
feel bad or we come up with a story that
makes us feel good which is man now i
know what i really want
uh now i'm ready for for the right
person you know you want to walk out
into the street and just look left and
right and say you know next you know i'm
ready and so there's a version of the
story that'll make you feel good or bad
in any given situation the power is in
being able to choose what the story is
and not just having the default one put
on you so that's my like mentality
mindset
ben what do you think you you've had
your fear of gut punches have you ever
had something like this
yeah i mean in crypto i think like a
year ago i had like a few eats stolen
out of my wallet and i was crushed and i
think i actually called you and i was
like dude it sucks i just lost a few eat
because i stupidly clicked on a discord
scam and i think what you said was
that's the price of admission every
single person in crypto has had that
happen and that's just what that's just
the name of the game uh
so i don't know my perspective on it is
like yeah definitely been got punched a
ton in crypto and i also feel like every
crypto i've ever gotten i'm mad that i
didn't sell it at the right time or i
held too long or
bought too late
uh i think that's the name of volatility
too so i'm just like that's the you know
i'm gonna get a huge home run because i
play this game and uh yeah learn from my
mistakes
yeah there's also like uh this phrase
with investing which is i've never done
i've never done an investment right
which means on an investment that worked
out i should have always been earlier
and bet more
and on an investment that's wrong i
shouldn't have bet or i you know i was
too late or whatever and so you'll never
ever on any investment feel like you did
it right you'll always be kind of
kicking yourself wishing you had done it
either bet bigger or better earlier or
whatever on it and so um
i think the thing you said that's right
which is it's the nature of the game
and so um you know crypto nfts this is
the wild wild west right now there's a
reason your nft can go up a
10x in price in one month or a hundred x
in price in a year or like you know i
don't know how much board apes are were
but like i think a year ago they were
under one east each and now they're like
whatever 140 or something like that so
you know 140x in a year so one of the
reasons you can get these types of gains
is because it's the wild wild west but
what comes with the wild wild west is
that
dude it's it's not safe uh there are
there are places where you could stub
your toe and
me and sam i think said this on a pod
once which was
if you become an entrepreneur or an
investor
and then
every time things go
anytime disaster strikes or things go
poorly or things go down
you're like emotionally a wreck because
of it and i'm not saying colin is but
it's very easy to become close to an
emotional wreck when things go down
uh it's like you
signed up to go you waited in line to go
on a roller coaster and you strapped
yourself in and then the roller coaster
went up and down and every time it went
down you were like oh like oh my god i
can't believe this like get me off this
thing it's like dude why did you get on
a roller coaster
you know like uh if you choose
entrepreneurship you choose investing if
you choose investing you got to wake up
and like the last four months dude i've
lost millions of dollars just because i
wake up and every day is red
stocks are red crypto is red
everything's red i haven't seen green in
months dude i don't even see the color
green right like i'm starting to text
people on android just so i can see the
green speech bubble dude like i just
want to see green and uh but that's the
reality it's like i signed up to be an
investor what did i think it's always
going to go up it's like i signed up to
you know do this crazy crypto stuff like
yes this crazy where you know
i'm playing this this this game where
you're you're a self-sovereign
individual you're custodian your own
assets well there's gonna be times where
you didn't custody it very well and it
got stolen um and so you know same thing
with with being an entrepreneur is
you gotta ask yourself am i just
complaining that the roller coaster went
up and down and uh and that's a way to
not let yourself be a victim i think one
of the most positive traits somebody can
have is that they never let themselves
be a victim no matter what happens in
their life they view themselves as the
person in control and the root cause of
whatever has occurred and in doing so
they give themselves the power to make
things good and they give themselves the
accountability when things go bad and so
um
so you know i think that's a just a
decision you got to make up front am i
going to let myself ever
play victim and look for kind of pity uh
self-pity or pity from others or you
just take that off the table you say
nope i'm never going to play that game
and so that means on days where my
gets stolen it did somebody didn't steal
my nfts i let my nfts be stolen and
right so you take control over what
happened and it hurts in those moments
but that decision to never play victim
is like one that pays off you know in
spades you know for the rest of your
life
ben what did i miss also it's a great
opportunity for a twitter thread right
here how i got my nft stolen
yeah this is the great this is the
beginning of every great story right uh
i've had this many times where i get a
cease and desist letter and then we turn
it into marketing for our company i've
had it where you know google or facebook
will launch a clone of our app
and your investors will send you a link
and be like hey did you see this like
yeah i saw it like i saw
that facebook has cloned our app you
know pixel by pixel and that you know
this you know 500 billion dollar company
is now competing with us yes i saw the
news but you know you got to sort of
like in that moment it's like this is
our chance this is our story of course
they're going to copy us we're on to
something right of course they're going
to copy us pixel 4 pixel because we have
the right solution right and you have to
decide what story you're going to tell
yourself and your team and your the
people around you so that again you're
going to feel some kind of way
would you rather feel bad or feel good
that's all you got to choose i tell ben
this all the time what ben started this
off talking about the suns winning
and ben how do you feel when the suns
win amazing ben how do you feel when the
suns lose
pretty pretty down on myself pretty down
on everything so you ride the roller
coaster and you let yourself feel bad
and so you know that's a choice you're
making right now at some point you might
decide to play the game differently
which is
i'm gonna
is it possible to feel great when your
team wins and not feel shitty when your
team loses yes that is possible
it sounds like it sounds like it's
breaking the rules but like that's what
you do when you're like a life hacker
he's like yeah you break the rules like
i'm gonna play the game i'm gonna play
the game on my terms
and uh and so there is a version of that
yeah and like when your businesses have
issues i think when the business have
issues like you don't let it get you
down at all uh
and you're you're able to take the wins
and stride really well do you have an
example of that like something where
we've we've taken we we've had a
situation where other people would have
felt down but we we spun it do you has
anything come to mind uh i mean i think
we're in one right now right like we
send the milk road and we've had some
deliverability issues recently where the
open rates have dropped a little bit and
we can't really tell you know we're
trying to figure out why and i think
there's one version where you freak out
about that
and you make it ruin your week or ruin
your day and there's another version
where you just take it in stride and
know you're gonna figure it out
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients whole history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a task from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
yeah like you know you fast forward a
year from now this will be a
forgotten footnote on the overall story
and even when things are really crazy
and you know something really bad
happens like you know in my e-commerce
business our entire shipment for
christmas got seized and flagged and
then inspected and then we had to do a
recall and like all this stuff and the
people you know people on my team were
all like
oh my god like just for this you know 1
8 of an inch you know this random random
seizure for no reason just because of
random inspection then
on one item they found a one-eighth of
an inch discrepancy oh my god this is so
unfair this is so bad blah blah
and it's like
all right like dude look like you know
we and i created a channel in our slack
called highs and lows and i said let's
put them here let's let's document the
highs and lows and i think every startup
should do this honestly is document the
highs and lows because it'll just get
you used to being like when you go in
there when things feel really bad and
you want to go in there and write it
down and you've it's like you see the
last one six months ago and you're like
oh yeah that felt pretty bad too but
i've like i've totally forgotten that
our business has grown 2x since then and
like oh you know just the way that that
one turned out to be nothing this one's
gonna be nothing too i'm gonna eat this
and i'm gonna like
use this as an opportunity to learn like
oh we didn't even know these
this one-eighth of an inch rule we had
to go like you know change the
measurements of something like i'm glad
we knew now versus when it's bigger
right i'm glad this happened because
that's gonna lead to all these good
things um and so you know there's uh we
had an example like this where
like i'll give you another one with our
e-commerce business uh the warehouse
manager that we had hired uh turned it
wasn't working out then we found out
they were trying to like you know sort
of like copy our business in a way and
like launch a competitor or something
like that because you know they're in
the warehouse they see businesses going
great so they wanted a piece of the
action
and this was a moment where
our team was sort of like you know
immediately felt betrayed and then upset
and was like well you know um what
should we do should we change you know
should we we're gonna have to make a
change it's gonna be so hard
and that those are the moments where you
need to show the most poise right that's
when
that's when strength matters is when
things get hard when things are easy is
not with strength matters so it's like
oh dude i've been training for this
i've been training for these types of
moments finally i got a reason to use
these muscles and that are that are in
my body to be able to be strong here and
so it was all about poise it was all
about basically coming up with all right
let's first be still let's not overreact
second let's decide how we're going to
approach this and respond to this
situation not react and then in that
response it turned out where
actually we ended up finding this
amazing manager and we ended up saving
all this money now we couldn't have seen
that up front in the moment it felt bad
now three months later or two months
later whatever it's like oh dude we
found this thing that's saving us you
know two dollars per order which is
going to add up to be hundreds of
thousands of dollars of extra profit
saved because
we found this new manager who found this
new process who found this new thing and
we would have never done that had that
disaster not struck and so once you go
through life enough you have enough
experience you realize oh
it's all working for me not against me
and once you decide it's all working for
me not against me then the next time the
disaster strikes like all right cool
what's this how is this working for me
and you don't panic you know the people
around you are like man how's this
person never panic they never freak out
about this stuff um that and then that
becomes the culture of the company
that's where you want to be
ironically i'm good at that and
everything except when it comes to
phoenix suns basketball
yeah well that's because you're fit
you're mentally fit
it's like you know you're mentally fit
with your upper body you never do leg
day right so it's like everybody's got
something in the gym where they're
really strong at it it's easy for them
it's hard for others and then they have
something that's
easy for others hard for them and that
might be calf raises that might be
whatever and so like you know
you could take a bodybuilder but you go
put them in a pilates class and they're
struggling because they don't have the
flexibility or the maybe the core
strength of coordination to be able to
do some some movements and so
everybody's got these moments that are
these situations that are harder for
them like ben wilson i'm curious for you
uh what's the thing give me yours what's
the adversity's disaster strike
situation where you're pretty good and
then what's the adversity or disaster
strike situation where you're pretty
weak
what's your version of leg day i'm
actually like um
because i'm a pretty relaxed person i
tend to do pretty well with adversity
um
but like
personal attacks really get to me like
like bad things happening in the world
um
don't don't bother me bad things for
other people don't care
things for me really care no but it can
have like if it hurts my bank account
even or like whatever like i just kind
of i move on with life
but if someone says something bad about
my character
um or
yeah insults me or something like that
the the one i think of that i think i
dealt with pretty well was
um
i was in barcelona
and as it relates to what this guy was
talking about and uh i'm sitting there
at like a
like a cafe so imagine a cafe i'm on la
rambla which is like a walking street
and so i'm facing this this big street
with a lot of people and i'm eating
dinner and i've got my phone on the
table and i'm
reading my phone as i eat dinner and
this old woman comes up to me
and sticks a sign
in my face
and
starts asking for money but the weird
thing is i speak spanish and she's not
speaking spanish
and i i don't know what she's saying
she's got a sign right in my face and
she's
she's speaking clearly asking for money
but i can't tell what she's saying and i
was like what i i don't understand you
and she keeps saying something like go
go away i try and kind of show her off
she leaves
i'm kind of shaken up and after like a
couple seconds reorienting myself i go
back to my dinner realization
there's someone that stuck the sign in
my face and underneath it had taken my
phone from off the table and i run off
and go search for her and of course even
if i'd found her she'd probably handed
it off to someone else and the phone was
gone and um
and that is the kind of thing that i
actually like deal with okay like
obviously i freaked out for a couple
minutes i was was really mad and was
stewing
but
uh eventually i was i just kind of like
was like
okay
i'm okay it was hard to explain like i
was freaking out because i didn't have a
phone in a foreign country and it was
like scary but i was like i'm okay i've
got all my fingers and toes and
it was like actually a good opportunity
to kind of like reevaluate of like all
right this is going to mess with a lot
of stuff but all the things that
actually matter in my life are not
affected by this dog being gone right
i'm gonna also give a technique uh
because one one part's the philosophy
another is a simple technique you can do
so how do you actually be still how do
you actually get to the response not the
thing
and it's really annoying when bad things
happen and then the advice you're
getting is like
it's okay don't worry about it shake it
off you know because it's like no in the
moment i feel i feel bad i feel some
sense of loss
uh you know and so you know it's very
hard and so the actual technique here is
a tony robbins technique that he calls
the 90 seconds of suffering and the
story is tony goes to india
and he's like he's taking he's taking
his platinum partners and these are the
dudes who's like you go to the beginner
tony robbins event you're like oh my god
this guy's the messiah and so you're
like oh if i pay 25k a year i get to go
on a trip with tony and like i get to be
a platinum partner and so you pay maybe
it's even more than it's 100k or
something like that you pay some crazy
amount of money and you become a
platinum partner so he took his platinum
partners to india to some like ashram in
the mountains and he's like you know
just giving them a unique experience and
he goes and this like kind of guru guy
in the mountains is like oh mr tony
robbins you know blah blah and he's like
he's like how are you he's like oh
fantastic you know life is amazing i
feel so grateful saying all the tony
robbins things in his like monster voice
and then they're like the guy was like
um
uh you know
i said something like you know but how
uh you know uh he said
so how are you dealing with your
suffering
and he's like
he's like uh suffering like the hell you
talking about bro like i'm tony robbins
uh i'm not suffering i'm mr positivity i
got my platinum partners here we're in
india i'm i'm teaching i'm not suffering
they might be suffering i'm not
suffering and he's like but i just saw
you a moment ago um you know you're
whatever your employee was saying about
the thing they forgot and you got so
upset you were telling them how they
should do it differently you you totally
changed your face
and he's like
oh well you know that was just we have
this i want this trip to be great for
our partners and you know this person
dropped the ball and uh yeah i guess i
kind of lost my cool but you know i i
really care about bubba and he's like he
caught himself he's like okay i'm just
justifying um he's like he's like that's
not suffering though suffering is like
you know
look around in india you see people
suffering on the streets and he's like
he's like it's the same thing they have
a deep different cause but they feel the
same thing they feel suffering in a
moment right and so he goes
he goes um you know you he's like you
are tony robbins i see you now and
you're you're you're you're bright and
you're happy you're lit up you're you're
energetic you've got the you have your
charisma all the stuff
and he's like don't make your happiness
so cheap tony robbins and he told him
and he was like um happiness cheap what
do you mean he goes that amy's like that
guy just did this small thing
and your happiness he took your
happiness
so your happiness had a very low price
it only took a very small thing to
acquire your happiness he took it away
from you
and so what you want to do and so my
takeaway from this was like
you want to have this like you want to
be the louis vuitton of happiness you
want your happiness to be very expensive
that it takes a very very big event even
bigger than all your nfts get stolen for
for somebody something to take it away
so you have to decide the price of your
happiness is your happiness going to go
away if someone gives you a wrong look
or cuts you off in traffic or you know
your delivery gets your pizza delivery
doordash gets delayed are you gonna get
upset and it not upset in a big way but
like you lose that joyful state of mind
you could otherwise be in and so he gave
himself this thing tony came up with
this technique called 90 seconds of
suffering he goes
okay so i started to notice these little
moments where i would lose my state i
would lose my state of mind where i
wasn't i was no longer in that kind of
happy grateful
you know
optimistic enthusiastic state of mind
he's like and i would just decide all
right i can't prevent
feeling that feeling like it's very hard
to just prevent it but i can contain it
and so he's like i'm going to give
myself 90 seconds
to suffer
and after the 90 seconds i got to let it
go but i get 90 seconds to
do it and of course what happens is like
you know if you don't give if you don't
time box it it's very easy to like have
something ruin your day
or even kind of get you down for a week
or a month or a year and you're
depressed all of a sudden so time boxing
is valuable but but the funny thing is
if you do the 90 seconds of suffering
we're like all right this happened
i'm gonna give myself 90 seconds
within like 24 seconds you'll be like
all right whatever i don't even need to
do the whole 90 like oh it's done like i
know it's gonna end anyways in 90
seconds do i really need to sit here and
wait the 90 to feel bad like if it's
going to end in 90 seconds anyway so you
don't even you end up not even doing 30.
and so that technique of like giving
yourself 90 seconds of suffering
whenever whatever happens has been like
pretty game-changing for me and so you
know i'd encourage you to do that all
right and if he's got stolen
all right have at it 90 seconds to
suffer suffer fully and as much as you
want for 90 seconds but the agreement is
at the end of that 90 you you no longer
get to get to suffer about this at the
end of the 90 you're going to take a
deep breath and you're going to change
the story in your head about what's
making you feel bad because it's not
that your nfts got stolen it's some
story about that it's how much money
you've lost how you're not going to get
them back how you spent so long
collecting them how that was your
favorite one
that story is what's making you feel bad
and that after 90 seconds you got to
change that story so that's my advice
for one question friday
that's it peace out
[Music]
you